there's a hole in my shirt just like how
there's a hole in that star star yes I'm
Greg I'm John
we're gonna watch Star Wars the Huayra
public announcement trailer I think this
was what that project luminous thing was
before hey speaking of Star Wars we were
on the road out recently that ties in
our life you know he's all about Star
Wars go check out our Motown match it
went up last week it's a really really
fun video I think you'll really like it
so just go watch it there's a link in
the description box and pin comment
anyhow let's watch this hi republic
announcement right love
[Music]
very cool right cool
[Music]
yes and the American Way
sit
[Music]
we're at a place of what's next for Star
Wars one of the things we've always done
is be able to use our franchise
platforms to explore the creative
potential in the Star Wars galaxy and so
what if publishing was more of an
incubation place and bring in great
talent and just let their imaginations
run free jump cuts in the audio it's
hoped you would always end up first
voices with very different opinions
about Star Wars this is a great Star
Wars movie
Larry's house their internet let's go on
the rich throw things out there we've
done lots of storytelling but this is
unique and really special
yeah idea that this thing has been
simmering for some more history than
that we gotta say yeah because way back
to the beginning of Star Wars we gave
them essentially a blank slate what
would you like to tell interesting
[Music]
pretty cool a line that we've been
hearing since 1977 and we thought you
know what does that look like
how far can we read into this little
channel to our peace and calm in the
galaxy so we're calling it the High
Republic the description that we've used
for the Jedi of this era is that they
are the jedi knights of the round table
nice but Star Wars isn't just about Jedi
and me will tell stories of new
smugglers new scoundrels new bounty
hunters the threat and the tension
really comes from the Republic's borders
because the Republic does not extend
from one side of the galaxy to the other
it's a bit of a patrols the frontiers
this is more of a Texas Ranger we're now
bringing in illustrators and visual
lists the same way that you would when
you're making a movie we even had okay
come down and just do sketch after
sketch for us when you have a guy who
designed the look for Darth Maul
sketching Jedi for you doesn't get any
cooler than this no it's true
you know this initiative is really new
for us we're going to have stories for
adults and teens and kids
we're building this out simultaneously
across multiple routers
it gives us the ability to tell the vast
interconnected Emma's space my king okay
you can't take it with you but we can
take it from you Ted
at all our story starts with what we're
calling the great disaster
it wouldn't be star wars without
adventure and there definitely is a
series of events that will spin the
galaxy into a dangerous new direction
and it'll give the opportunity for
Heroes to rise up the cool thing about
this episode be a story for every Star
Wars
it's really fun to be able to keep
readers on the tones this era is ripe
for storytelling the Eureka moment was
the question who upstairs the Jedi that
made us all ooh something would get this
way comes
yeah that's supposed to experience fear
what scares the Jedi are space and
there's got to be an answer in the
technological Information Age or there's
mass consumption of all kinds of
television and film media and where
they're having a hard time getting the
fanbase to watch the movies they're
gonna put all their cards I'm making
sure everyone's gonna be reading instead
what was the one thing everybody brought
up in this most recent line of movies oh
yes the extended universe if ignored
let's reboot that what happens after
Rises Skywalker and have the Skywalker's
ha goes over oh I know I know let's just
keep going back don't bad back 200 that
seems to be what's working for us
there's more in betweens and more
prequels go way back yeah it does still
take that we're gonna unpack that one
line other than that I feel like this
could be anywhere like like what they're
talking about wanting to do which you
know I'm not an expert in the extended
universe but it seems like they're just
kind of rebooting their extended
universe in a morning by the way
yes seems like they could literally
place these stories anywhere at a
certain point I don't feel like they'd
even need to stick to however many
hundred years hundreds of years ago you
just tell stories at any time yet I
stories are cool and all not surprised
but I pride you a little bit more
intrigued if it was more than just more
Jedi stories to come because there's a
new smuggler yeah there's gonna be the
Nile the space Viking is which which
does look cool I like the idea that they
brought a McKay back for like the
aesthetic designs for certain Jedi Khan
since he worked on Darth Maul that looks
pretty neat this is like some of the
best marketing I've ever seen for a book
like a book series it's cool there's
spanning all these different mediums of
novelizations and comics and whatnot in
some ways there's like a worrisome
element to me in other ways there's a
really exciting element to me and I
think that's kind of a cool
middle-of-the-road
spot to be at because usually when you
see a writers room that big that's a
setup for disaster a lot of the time
like what do we want and ice critic a
screenshot of this and I haven't read
through it yet but I was when we were
doing the reaction I was like I got a
screenshot this but they have this board
here I have on screen fiction Star Wars
Star Wars of witches fiction
authentically lived in surprise
diversity actual feeling relatable
characters sweeping / epic and they they
should have called that section basic
forms of storytelling this is everything
that is just pretty basic maybe the
diversity thing is a good thing to point
out I want to know what conversation led
to the formation of this list I yeah
because yeah these are all things that I
would definitely OPC from the Star Wars
or any other sorry Star Wars
heart love not pro-war that's a good
point
droids amen scope mythic space and
lightsaber battles no single main
character the force complicated monsters
and the Star Wars wishes all right read
it off hi republic relic hunters that's
out of the box you University Star Wars
you study the force you can study the
darks dinosaurs enthusiastically
dinosaurs representation and diverse
whoa whoa whoa diversity is already on
the question side for Siddarth Rhodes
doesn't exist or not alright look enough
of your whoa culture crap Arthurian
legends you okay I don't think that
rival houses yes Game of Thrones Sith
Empire Kaos agents at man splinter group
force users that could be cool that
sounds really really
let's keep splintering the force
actually I would love that okay so what
encompasses all this [ __ ]
let's go way back Jenny knows Jedi's not
on here once no no no this might not be
the full board that's true then we were
there are like 86 could be really maybe
this is just yeah what Snyder's talking
a ladder yeah yeah son of those like
professor librarian or guys on a sliding
ladder right yeah this is directors kind
of this very advertisement got every
writer to sit down and write their
favorite things about fiction Star Wars
and what they wish for still I'm very
much torn between two things which is
they made that comparison of like we
were treating this like it's a movie and
I felt like I was watching a commercial
for a movie yeah and like really in the
advertising side of this props to the
use of footage they really got me
engrossed in this um but you know on a
more a genuine side of things I do hope
you know like some of these things
they've written on this board do seem
like neat expansions or neat things to
hone in on in a Star Wars true on
texture well you know it would be nice
to just do purely original stories I
feel like the world of Star Wars allows
for hopefully the flow of originality
through a familiar framework so yeah
like I can see how this might be cool
and how Disney or whoever might be smart
in going hey what we've learned through
the bumpy experience of doing these new
sequels is people actually have a huge
amount of love and respect for the you
know print side of the universe and for
the potential that that whole yes I
really hope that they mean what they say
when they're you know putting all this
originality and creativity into this
project well the fact that they're doing
a storytelling through books and comics
I think you gotta be a lot more free I
think you got to explore a lot more
different things it can't just boil down
to Jedi and Sith again especially when
they're talking about this the great
disaster that they're talking about the
high republic is I like the idea of an
insidious threat in terms of when the
galaxy was a lot more glorious a lot
more positive there's something seeping
in slowly just don't make it the Sith
again I want to write the book it takes
place in the utopian society where there
is no conflict no complication have Jedi
yeah exactly
out to dismantle the Jedi right sit
around smoking pipes all day that's why
I called the high order and nothing else
to do is sit around and smooth alright
guys well are you gonna read in any of
these maybe a comic I don't think I'll
read a book guys subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification to get
notified whenever we got a video up
check out all our Star Wars content my
goal here's I finally made an official
goal and then I'll catch up on all of
the Clone Wars before Mandalorian season
two comes out that way I feel like I'm
really I understand a connective tissue
a lot better especially with the way
mental racism one ended any here
see guys